what would happen if you would lose your
job would you still be able to pay your
bills and provide for your family just a
couple of years ago for me the answer
would have been no i worked in
consulting well i surely couldn't
complain about my salary if i would have
lost that job i would have had a big
problem because that was by far the most
significant income stream thankfully
over the last years i was able to break
free from this dependency on only
relying on one stream of income so in
this video i want to give you an insight
into my journey into what i did so
welcome to another coffee break here on
my channel firm learning my name is
heinrich and on my channel i want to
help you to become successful in the
first years of your career so in this
video i'm first going to show you the
income streams that i build for myself
and second some tips how you can do
similar things as well that makes sense
to you i recently read several articles
the claim that an average millionaire
has about 7 income streams to his or her
disposal so this motivated me to look
into my income streams as well and it
turns out that i also have seven income
streams at the moment unfortunately i'm
no millionaire and the truth is also
that it wasn't always like that this is
only something that i built over the
last years so if we look back into 2019
what my situation was then i was working
and consulting and 98
of my income was derived from this
consulting job already at that time
before i even started this youtube
channel i had some online courses on
topics like communications and slight
writing skills and i was earning a
handful of extra bucks by selling these
courses but as you can see i was still
heavily relying on my job thankfully the
situation improved already in 2020 i was
making about a quarter of my income not
from my full-time regular employment and
in 2021 i managed to derive almost
two-thirds of my income outside of my
regular job and this is true even though
until today i still work in a full-time
job and also with a healthy development
of my salary so how did i make this work
for myself and for that let's deep dive
into my income in 2021 what's probably
surprising is the income that i derive
from a full-time job so after having
worked at mckinsey for about six years
and consulting i now work as chief
revenue officer for munich-based
property technology company but let's
now also talk about the other six income
streams and i want to start by the
income streams that are most closely
related to the youtube channel because
fun fact whenever you tell someone that
you have a youtube channel the first
question usually is okay so how many
subscribers do you have but then the
second question is so how much do you
earn with it right so this is a question
that somehow seems to be very close to
the mind of many people doing this
surely when i started my youtube channel
in january 2020 i wouldn't even have
believed that this whole commercial part
is a big part of it all so i do hope
that this alone is also an inspiration
to some of you for people who maybe are
thinking about starting similar projects
like this and the first thing that maybe
comes to mind when thinking about a
youtube channel is the youtube ad
revenue so whenever youtube shows an ad
on your channel the content creator
receives a revenue share of the income
that youtube gets from the company so
order the ad for larger channels this ad
income alone can mean a six digit or
even seven digit annual income so while
i'm surely still far away from that it
still provides me a solid eight percent
share of the income that i'm making
today next is sponder ships so this is
like the second thing that comes to mind
if you think about monetizing a youtube
channel so yes i think it's no secret
that companies approach creators
approach me and ask whether i would be
willing to collaborate with them on any
specific service or product they're
offering i can tell you that i'm quite
selective on accepting these
sponsorships so almost every day i now
receive requests like this but then for
those companies that you do accept as
sponsors of course you receive a
compensation for the collaboration and
these types of deals amounted to 18 of
my income last year next is affiliate
sale so also one of these typical online
business revenue streams that exist out
there how this works is that for
instance in my video description you see
different products different things
services linked in there and whenever
someone purchases a product or a service
we are one of these links i receive a
certain revenue share from these
purchases but as you can see this income
stream is rather a minor one for me i
know that for some other creators this
is actually one of the largest income
streams for their social media platforms
for myself i didn't really figure out
yet the winning formula for all of this
next is online courses and here also
include all the other digital products
that i have for instance cv templates or
cover letter templates you find links to
them in the video description as you saw
in the beginning this is actually the
additional revenue stream i started with
and of course having a platform like a
youtube channel helps in selling more
courses like that so thanks to everyone
who purchased one of these courses in
the past i do hope that there are true
value add for you and very much worth
the money i'm actually currently working
on a major overhaul of my courses and
i'm about to join my new communications
and slide writing flagship course so if
you're interested in that there will be
a link with the wait list below in the
video description feel free to sign up
to be informed once it goes live next is
business school lectures so we are some
of my online courses and maybe a little
bit also the youtube channel i got in
contact with several business schools
that i now conduct lectures for the most
notable of these engagements is the
university of zangalan where i teach in
the full-time and part-time mba program
on professional development skills this
is of course also compensated and now
contributes to percent of my income so
which is the last income stream that is
missing which actually is my second
largest income stream at the moment and
this might surprise some of you because
i haven't talked about this much here on
my channel but it's actually corporate
trainings so over the last two years or
so also via my online courses youtube
videos and so on i've been contacted by
several companies to provide corporate
trainings for some of the teams these
topics also mainly focus on
communication slight writing and problem
solving skills and this is now a good
solid extra income for myself that
provides about 19 of the money that i
made last year so this is the full
picture of my income streams what's
maybe very worthwhile to notice is
what's not included here and these are
all capital gains dividends and so on so
the past already created a video about
my perspective on investing i will link
it also somewhere above here if you
watch that you know that i invest the
majority of the money that i do not need
to finance my life into capital markets
the majority of my money is in etfs that
automatically reinvest the dividends
which is why i do not have any active
income from that now that you've seen
the full picture would be interested in
your perspective as well does all of
this surprise you did you already build
some extra income streams besides your
full-time job as well because now i want
to share some more general tips on what
you could do as well to build some
additional income streams and
potentially get a bit more independent
from your regular full-time job and the
first idea is the concept of the surface
area of luck because surely it takes
some luck to build something like this
some youtube channel for instance surely
i was lucky that several of my videos
got picked up by the youtube algorithm
shown to many people like you and
thereby contributing to the growth of my
channel and they're also contributing to
many of the income streams but what most
definitely is not a winning strategy is
just to sit at home at your desk and
wait for your lucky moment that
something magical happens and suddenly
out of nothing good things come to you i
mean this is not how it works instead
you should pursue things that widen your
surface area widen the possibilities
that something lucky like this might
happen to you are you into photography
that's great develop and hone your
skills maybe you're into a very specific
sport pursue that what's important
though is to not expect that from any of
these passions or activities from yours
on day one you will already make money i
would never have thought when i started
this youtube channel that now almost 20
of my income would come from delivering
corporate training sessions increase
your surface area of luck and good
things will happen to you as well second
think about the time that you
systematically waste during your week
surely there's no problem in
occasionally also relaxing watching a tv
series netflix gaming or whatever pushes
your buttons though what might
potentially be problematic is if you
make it a habit of yours that every
single evening say after 7 pm you do all
these things consistently every single
day i am convinced that how your life
will look like in five years will very
much be determined by this time that you
invest in your evenings in your spare
hours whether you value your own time
and make it count do to some extent
something productive with it or not and
third and this might be a hard truth for
some of us to swallow so i was surely
not in a position not able to do all
these things invest all the time that
are investing today to build all these
things while i was still working and
consulting the job was just too
demanding every day during the work week
i was working very late hours on the
weekend i was just tired most of the
time and just wouldn't have had the
clear head just of thinking about things
like this so while i think it's very
valid and for sure for me it was the
right decision to in your 20s also early
30s pick such a high paced career that
really provides you with lots of
learnings at some point everyone needs
to ask his or herself this question
whether picking up a job with maybe a
bit more regular working hours wouldn't
be a good idea not only for family which
is of course a big dimension in this
whole decision process as well but also
just to have the flexibility to pursue
some extra opportunities like this so
these are just my two cents on the topic
so i'm surely not saying and
recommending that everyone should start
a youtube channel they do think that
there are many other ways to make
something productive with some hobbies
and skills of yours but now again let me
know in your comments what is your
perspective are you already building
something like this how has your journey
been looking like i trust this might be
very inspirational maybe also to some of
the more junior people here in the
audience as always if you took any value
out of this video at all please destroy
the like button for the youtube
algorithm and also subscribe and turn on
the notification bell to stay up to date
on all my content big big thanks to all
the members of the channel and for your
support this is very much appreciated my
name is heinrich i'm the creator of this
channel i release new videos every
single saturday so looking forward to
stay in touch with you all the best to
you until next week bye